Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio mit der Nummer 288 und zum ersten Chaos Radio im Jahr 2024 zu einem Thema, das einerseits ganz alt ist und andererseits auch ganz aktuell. Es geht um Hacker in Filmen und Hackerinnen. Vielleicht auch das werden wir sozusagen genauer ergründen müssen. Also es geht darum, wie die Menschen, über die wir hier im Chaos Radio häufiger sprechen, dargestellt werden in einem fiktiven Medium, das in unser aller Alltag eine sehr, sehr große Rolle spielt. Und der besondere Anlass dafür ist, dass jemand, also Hacker in Filmen vielleicht schon mal gehört, ganz explizit geschaut hat, wie ist es eigentlich im deutschen bewegt Bild, um diesen Namen an dieser Stelle auch mal sagen zu können. Und deswegen sind wir heute sehr viele Menschen hier, zum Beispiel Konstanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Tag. Ich weiß immer nicht, als was bist du eigentlich hier? Bist du jetzt als Pressesprecherin des CCC oder Redakteurin von Netzpolitik Org oder als freischaffende Hackerfilmguckerin oder als was bist du heute hier?
Also ich finde das hat noch einen anderen Aspekt bei The Billion Dollar Code. Also wenn ich mir so die frühen Hackerfirmen angucke, die ich bestimmt mehr gesehen habe als sozusagen die neuzeitlichen, dann fällt halt auf, dass es gibt kein Berufsbild Hacker. Es sind so mehr so Autodidakten und irgendwie so Wunderkinder oder sie haben irgendwelche speziellen Fähigkeiten. Und heute gibt es ein Berufsbild Hacker. Es gibt eine ganze Szene sozusagen, die aus verschiedenen Sichten das beruflich tut und mittlerweile auch in aufgefächerte Form. Das sind ja nun beileibe nicht nur Hacker, die im Auftrag zum Beispiel in Systeme einbrechen, weil der Besitzer der Systeme sie dazu auffordert oder so. Sondern das ist ja auch eine ganze Beratungsbranche. Mittlerweile also Leuten helfen in der Defensive gegen Angriffen, in der Analyse von Angriffen. Also heute gibt es ja richtig ein Berufsbild und ich finde, so langsam sickert es auch in diese Filmmeldein. Und da ist für mich Berlin Dollar Code mal ein Beispiel. Das wird nämlich trotzdem, Atom kommt jetzt bestimmt nicht gerade, ein typischer Fall ist von Company, aber es hat ein Company.
Aber ich wollte gerade fragen, ist das noch Hacking im Sinne von, wie man auch fragen kann, ist etwas noch Indie oder ist etwas noch Punk? Also wenn ich für eine Billion Dollar Company irgendwie Computer Defense mache, bin ich dann noch ein Hacker? Oder ist das sozusagen so wie zu sagen, die späten toten Hosen sind Punk?
Ich würde klar werden, aber das liegt natürlich auch daran, dass die Leute Hacker kennen, die das heute faktisch tun. Egal ob sie jetzt für eine kleinere Klitsche arbeiten oder für eine große Klitsche, meine persönliche Meinung ist, wenn du in der Defense bist, dann bist du schon noch Hacker.
Okay, weil ich hatte oder das mediale Bild, das fiktionale Bild vom Hacker ist immer auch das der Unabhängigkeit. Und die Frage ist, ist es dann noch gegeben, wenn man? Genau, das ist die Frage. Ist das noch so und wird das dem entsprechen oder ist das einfach ein altes Bild, was nicht mehr so ist? William, was sagst du denn?
Also in den Filmen, wenn die Hauptfigur versucht, etwas allein zu schaffen, kommt das immer zum Katastroph. Also man braucht die Hacker-Freunde, um zu kollaborieren. Deswegen würde ich euch fragen, ob diese Entwicklung positive Wirkung hat, dass man jetzt kollaborativer wird und das Hacker verbessert. Oder gibt es noch Einzelgänger, die alles allein zu schaffen versuchen?
Ich glaube eigentlich, dass es die noch nie gab. Wenn man sich die frühe Hacker-Ethik ansieht, auch die, die es schon vor dem TTC gab, also sozusagen Steven Levy im Original, war ja eigentlich diese Teilgewissen immer dabei. Und das glaube ich auch tatsächlich enorm wichtig. Aber wenn man es jetzt wieder bezieht auf die heutige Hacker-Welt, dann ist das in jeder Hinsicht professionalisierte Arbeitsteilung. Denn keiner kann die Fähigkeit alleine haben, auch nicht mehr in der Defensive. Also die Professionalisierung in diesem Hacker-Feld, die ist natürlich genau mit dieser Arbeitsteilung verbunden. Und mit dem Information-Sharing. Aber auf dieser sozusagen ehrenamtlichen Ebene, in den Hacker-Szenen, bevor das irgendwie mal ein Berufsbild wurde, war das glaube ich schon immer drin. Also bevor der ZZC angefangen hat, die Hacker-Ethik sozusagen in Deutsch umzuschreiben, war das ja schon Teil, würde ich zumindest so sehen. Casper guckt so im Mittel.
Ja, ich denke gerade drüber nach. Ich glaube, es hängt halt sehr stark mit der Technikgeschichte zusammen. Also in den 80er, 90er Jahren war es schwer, Informationen zu teilen, einfach auf rein technologischer Basis. Und heutzutage ist es der Norm, heutzutage ist es schwer, Informationen nicht zu teilen.
Ja, aber heute musst du sie teilen, um Komplexität herzulegen.
Damit wollte ich erst mal sagen, heutzutage ist es der Normalfall, sowas wie GitHub zu benutzen, ein Tool, um Code zu hosten. Das ist eine bekannte Plattform und da können mehrere Entwicklerinnen gleichzeitig an Code arbeiten. Das ist so ein Quasi-Standard, den nutzen viele. Das wäre vor 30 Jahren schwierig gewesen, also zu arbeiten, auch wenn es solche Ansätze gab. Und deswegen sind die Tools heute da und gleichzeitig werden sie benötigt, weil wenn an einem Hack gearbeitet wird, wir können ja mal ein Beispiel geben, auf dem letzten Kongress wurde gezeigt, wie ein Zug wieder reanimiert wurde. Das ist sehr spannend, weil das ein hochkomplexes Ding war und da mussten aber mehrere Personen dran arbeiten, weil das die technische Kompetenz einer Person überfordert, weil eine muss sich sehr gut mit Hardware auskennen, eine mit bestimmten Komponenten von Software, weil Software- und Hardware-Projekte so komplex sind, dass mehrere Personen dran arbeiten müssen.
Ein wunderbares Beispiel. Du kennst sicherlich, ich frage jetzt Will, sicherlich auch diese frühe Form der Hackerethik und ob da nicht schon immer mit dabei war, dass man gar nicht alleine kann, sondern quasi kollaborieren muss.
Ja, und in den Filmen gibt es immer einen Visionären, würde ich sagen, ein Robin Hood. Aber ja, der effektive Robin Hood braucht auch seine Räuberbande, um erfolgreich zu sein, um dem Publikum zu helfen.
Aber jetzt klingt es gerade so, als wäre ein Hacker in Filmen sozusagen immer Teil einer Bande. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, ist das wirklich so oder nur in den Filmen so, wo das im Mittelpunkt steht? Ich hatte ja ganz am Anfang noch sozusagen diese Vermutung gehabt, es gibt den Hacker als Sidekick, also wie ein Die Hard 4 oder so. Aber da sind die schon immer Teil einer dann im Film unsichtbaren, aber es ist immer Teil, dass die klar sind, Teil einer Welt, wo sie auch eine Subkultur. Genau, Teil einer Subkultur.
Stimmt, das Wort Subkultur ist heute noch nicht gefallen.
Ja, Gott sei Dank haben wir das gesagt.
Ich habe aber noch eine andere Frage und zwar, mein Eindruck von Hacker-Filmen ist immer, dass die immer auch, wir reden jetzt immer über deren primäre Elemente, also dem Umgang mit Rechenmaschinen und dem Widerstand gegen ein System und dem Regelbruch und so weiter und so fort. Ich hab aber so, also auf so einer zweiten Hacke hab ich das Gefühl, Hacker in Filmen sind grundsätzlich auch Leute, die irgendwie noch eine Übersetzungshilfe für den Rest der Menschheit brauchen. Also ich hab das Gefühl, es gibt sehr oft noch, dass die Hacker-Figur noch eine Figur an der Seite hat, die dafür zuständig ist, mit dem Rest der Gesellschaft zu interagieren. Also gerade so, als wäre der Hacker auch eine komische Maschine, die von der Gesellschaft bedient werden müsste. Und das ist selbst in einem Film, also jetzt wieder Spoiler, selbst in dem Film Who Am I? Das ist eine Geschichte von vier Hackern. Und da gibt es einen, der ist sozusagen immer die Schnittstelle zu den ganzen sozialen Fertigkeiten. Da stellt sich am Ende heraus, der ist gar kein echter Hacker, weil er gar nicht programmieren kann, sondern nur ein Skript-Key, die ist, wie er von sich selbst sagt. Also jemand, der sozusagen nur Dinge kopiert und nicht selber das wirklich kann. Und ist das auch eine Gemeinschaft, die ihr von, also in der Hacker-Erzählung in Filmen seht, nämlich dass der Hacker so ein bisschen als sozial unbedarft dargestellt wird, also gerade als ob es so einen Zusammenhang gäbe zwischen ich verstehe Computer, deswegen verstehe ich Menschen nicht. Ist das was, was Hacker-Filme und Filmhacker erzählen?
Doch, doch. In 23, in Who Am I gibt es Hauptfiguren, die sozusagen zu fern in den Himmel gegangen sind und sie brauchen Nebenfiguren, Sidekick Hacker, die sie zurück in die Welt bringen. Und es ist andersrum in Billion Dollar Code. Also die Nebenfigur braucht die Hilfe der Hauptfigur um seine existenzielle Problem zu lösen.
Ich gebe einfach an euch noch weiter zu dem, was Wilhelm gerade gesagt hat, dass der Hacker also immer jemanden im Prinzip braucht. Seht ihr das auch so?
Und ist das nicht Teil der Identität eines Genies, dass wenn man so viel weiß, hat man Probleme, zu Recht zu kommen mit der Menschheit?
Das stimmt, das Geniale haben wir glaube ich auch noch nicht angesprochen.
Also ich versuch das gerade durch so Filmbeispiele mir durch den Kopf gehen zu lassen. Die Frage ist für mich jetzt, kommt der Hacker oder die Hackerin alleine in der Welt zurecht oder nicht? Ja, also muss jemand dabei sein? Und es gibt auf jeden Fall Hacker, die irgendjemanden brauchen, der sie durchleitet. Das ist ja auch ein bisschen ein Klischee, der Nerd, der irgendwie nicht so richtig weiß. Es gibt aber auch extrem selbstbewusste Charaktere. Wir hatten vorhin über Lisbeth Salander gesprochen. Die kommt zurecht.
Auf ihre Art. Aber sie kommt zurecht. Also ja, aber ich frage mich schon, ob hier sozusagen eine Erzählung tradiert wird, die man auch gerne benutzt, weil sie halt das Erzählen einfacher macht. Also wenn ich in einem Film eine Geniefigur habe oder jemand, der sozusagen die Schnittstelle zum komplexen System ist, wenn ich dem dann sozusagen wieder eine Schwäche anhängen kann, dann ist das ja, was das macht, das Erzählerische einfach. Er wird dann eben nicht so sehr zum Superheld. Und gleichzeitig tradiert das ja das Klischee vom weltfremden Technik-Nord, der irgendwie sozial so ein bisschen inapt ist. Von daher frage ich mich schon, ob das narrative Faulheit auch ist, das sozusagen immer weiter zu tradieren.
Ja, aber ich glaube auch realweltlich wird ganz sehr oft irgendwie so eine Genialität zugeschrieben oder jedenfalls mehr als notwendig bewundert, was sie mit Computer können. Also ich erlebe schon gerade so bei Leuten, die eine gewisse Ehrfurcht vor Technik haben, das ist ja relativ verbreitet, dass Menschen auch eine gewisse Angst vor Technik haben oder sich ein bisschen ohnmächtig fühlen, dass derjenige, der diese Technik beherrscht, überhöht wird. Das nehm ich in der Realität auch. Insofern spiegelt sich der, glaube ich, nur wat wieder, warum sollen Filme machen, die das anders sehen als viele Menschen in der Realität. Und es gibt so einen Übersprung. Dadurch, dass Hacker auch in den früheren Filmen immer so als genial und so als mit übermäßigen Fähigkeiten dargestellt werden, reproduziert sich das ja auch. Auch in der Realität, finde ich.
Also ich muss ganz kurz eine Anekdote aus meinem Leben erzählen. Ich hab ein paar Jahre auf einem Dorf gelebt, jetzt in den letzten Jahren. Und mir wurde irgendwann zugetragen, dass über mich dort die Geschichte kursierte. Man solle es sich nicht mit mir verscherzen, weil ich könnte dann die Konten der Person hacken. So, weil ich halt irgendwie, naja.
Hackfähigkeiten.
Weil ich irgendwie was mit Technik und das war so, und ich konnte auch nie erklären, was ich als Dayjob arbeite. Und weil du hast gerade gesprochen von so einer narrativen Faulheit. Und Constanze hat, glaube ich, gegen gehalten und gesagt, nee, das ist einfach die Geschichte, die in der Gesellschaft kursiert. Deswegen ist es nicht die Faulheit, sondern das Wiedererzählen einer Geschichte. Und ich würde da mitgehen, dass das Tatsache, also die mehr geht um.
Ja, aber genau, aber das würde ich so, das ist das, was mit narrativer Faulheit meine. Also ich tradiere das Klischee weiter, statt mir die Mühe zu, also gerade, wir haben ja festgestellt, im deutschen Bezug ist immer sozusagen die Lust an der Authentizität. Also das soll also was haben. Und wenn ich dann so sagen, aber bei der einen Sache sage, na gut, aber es ist schon irgendwie sehr praktisch, wenn auch ich erzählen kann, wie irgendwie wir nerdy und unbeholfen, die in sozialen Situationen sind. Das ist ja, weiß ich nicht, würde ich mir mehr wünschen.
Diese drei Fälle, dass eine Figur, die sehr schüchtern ist und eine, die ganz charismatisch ist und kommt auf den Fall an, welche existenzielle Probleme hat. Aber man merkt, ja, das ist ganz symbiotisch. Man braucht einander. Also in 22 braucht Karl Koch seinen Freund David. In Who Am I braucht Benjamin den Max. Und ja, wenn sie sich trennen, dann schatten sie nichts.
Vielleicht versteige ich mich jetzt gerade total. Aber ich habe auch manchmal sozusagen so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass wenn man Hacker als Helden sind, dass das auch so ein Vehikel ist. Man könnte sogar transportieren im Sinne, vielleicht hat die Welt Angst vor Hackern. Also wenn die jetzt nicht nur die digitale Welt kontrollieren, sondern auch noch sozial empathisch fit sind, dann hält die ja niemand mehr auf. Dann sind wir alle verloren. Hacker als Weltherrschaft.
Also es gibt so eine Figur, die mir einfällt, ein Passwort Swordfish. Der Hacker, der sieht cool aus. Gespielt von John Travolta, glaube ich.
Nee, weder noch. Ach, das ist nicht, nee, der heißt.
Nein, nicht John Travolta, war völlig falsch. Aber ich sag mal so ein schicker Amerikaner. Ja, der ist schnittig. Ein schnittiger Typ jedenfalls. Und es gibt eine Szene, die sexuell auch sehr explizit ist, wo, sagen wir mal, an ihm, ich umschreib's jetzt mal jugendfrei, sexuelle Handlungen vollzogen werden, während er einen Hack ausführen muss unter Zeitdruck. Ja, das kann sein, genau. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Wie komm ich denn auf John Travolta? Der spielt auch mit, der spielt mit in dem Film.
Aber der ist nicht der Hacker.
Nee, nee, genau. Der spielt mit, aber genau. Ich hab die beiden verwechselt. Mein Namensgedächtnis. Jedenfalls sieht er ganz anders aus als die Hacker vorher. Wie ja auch in Matrix, die dann schon ein bisschen anders aussehen. Und das war aber auch eine verstörende Hackerfigur dadurch. Tatsache. So.
Jetzt muss ich aber auch Angelina Jolie sagen.
Oh, einer der besten Hackerfilme überhaupt jetzt.
Genau, also nur um mal sagt zu haben.
Sag mal den Film nochmal.
Weißt du, wie der hieß?
Mit Angelina Jolie, der Hackerfilm?
Du hast den Hackerfilm mit Angelina Jolie nicht gesehen?
Das ist ja kein deutscher Hackerfilm.
Stimmt, der ist ja kein deutscher Hackerfilm.
Also ich finde, einer der besten amerikanischen Hackerfilme, weil er super lustig ist. Einfach Hacker mit Angelina Jolie. Hack the Planet ist einfach kurzweilig.
Ja und ist auch kulturell interessant.
Ja und es gibt eine tolle Hackszene auch. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, wie zeigt man Hacken. Da gibt es einen Hacker-Battle, der glaube ich so dargestellt wird, dass ein Roboterarm immer Datasetten oder so aus einem Schrank rausholt um die Wette. Also da versucht man das durch so Roboter-Tätigkeiten irgendwie darzustellen. Genau, genau. Also das ist auf jeden Fall, kann man den sich angucken.
Vielleicht ist das dann wirklich auch die Stelle, wo wir dahin zurückkommen können zu der Darstellung, zu der guten oder schlechten Darstellung von Hacks in Filmen und die jetzt auch sozusagen vielleicht auf das Deutsche, auf deutsche Filme und Fernsehen zurückgegriffen. William, was ist denn für dich sozusagen die beste Analogie für was da im Computer passiert, wie sie in Filmen dargestellt wird?
Wenigstens diese Angst, dass man die ganze Welt beherrscht und dass es böse Richten im Internet gibt, kommt vor allem in der Serie You Are Wanted vor. Das ist mit Matthias Schweighöfer, der ist ganz prominent in Deutschland. Aber ja, die Serie schafft es zu zeigen, wie integriert alles heutzutage ist. Und wenn was integriert ist, dann ist das Teil dieses Systems und dadurch ganz hackbar.
Ich fürchte wir haben jetzt ein bisschen aneinander vorbeigeredet, weil was ich meinte ist sozusagen die visuelle Repräsentation davon, wie gehackt wird. Also wir hatten ja schon gesprochen über die U-Bahn, die das Darknet ist in Who Am I? Und sagen die Frage sozusagen was daran, also an visuellen Repräsentationen von Hacking, was dir da aufgefallen ist, was besonders gut gelungen ist. Und ja, ich möchte nachher noch sozusagen zu den Fails kommen. Jetzt aber erstmal, was ist eine gute Repräsentation von Hacking?
Ach so, ja, wenn man auf dem Schirm Programmiersprache im Computer sieht, ja, ist das für normale Menschen so, okay, der Computer ist ganz kaputt und ja, hat ein Virus darauf. Und ja, da so wird oftmals in jenen dargestellt. Also man versteht nicht, was auf dem Schirm passiert oder was der Schirm sagt. Man weiß nur, okay, ein Hacker hat das kaputt gemacht.
Aber hast du eine Analogie, wo das eine gute Repräsentation hat? Also vielleicht sozusagen ein zweites Beispiel zu der U-Bahn, die das Darknet darstellt. Also wo da künstlerische Formen gefunden sind, die das nach erlebbar nachvollziehbar machen?
In 23 zum Beispiel ist man so am Telefon und man hat ein ganz altes Laptop dabei und man sieht auf dem Schirm, es gibt Lokalitäten und es gibt Nummern und Zahlen, die zeigen, ja, man hat reingehackt und dann kommt es zu Problemen. Ich finde die Darstellungen in 23 ganz realistisch, aber auch ja zeitgenossen. Zeitgenosserschaft.
Wir fallen zwei gute Beispiele ein. Ich finde, eine Sache wurde gut in War Games dargestellt aus den 80er Jahren, nämlich das War Dialing, also das Durchprobieren von Telefonnummern, um auf Daten zuzugreifen. Das wurde einfach gezeigt, das sah sehr schick aus. Und in den USA ist wohl zu Weihnachten auch der Verkauf von Computer Modems enorm in die Höhe gestiegen, was auch spannend ist in Bezug auf der Wechselwirkung von Hacker Szene und Film. Und dann noch ein anderes Beispiel, das vielleicht ein bisschen überraschend ist, von Legacy, eine Disney-Produktion. Da gibt es, Konstant sitzt die Augenbrauen hoch, da gibt es einen Hacker-Battle, wo also zwei Hacker sich bekriegen. Und auf der einen Seite sieht man, was der für Befehle eingibt im Computer. Und auf der Kommandozeile am Computer gibt es Befehle, die einfach auf Englisch sind und die sind sehr gut nachvollziehbar. Zum Beispiel Befehle wie Kill. Und in dieser Szene werden diese Befehle eingegeben. Und auch wenn Zuschauer nicht wirklich wissen, was dort passiert, ist es einerseits relativ realistisch, weil man benutzt diese Befehle, um zum Beispiel Programme, ich sag mal zum Absturz zu bringen oder zu beenden. Und andererseits versteht sie auch jemand, der nicht programmieren kann. Und es gibt dazu auch einen Blogpost, wo der Visual Artist von Tron Legacy erklärt, wie es zu dieser Szene gekommen ist. Der hat sich da einfach eingemischt und hat gesagt, lass uns das mal so machen. Und deswegen gibt es diese eine Szene in den Tron Legacy, die ich wirklich richtig gut fand.
Also wenn ich jetzt ein Computer wäre, würde ich diese Antwort zurückgeben, weil ich ja nach deutschen Filmen gesagt habe, aber ich will mal nicht so sein.
Ich werde keine Zähne hinzufügen, aber ich muss, ich muss ein Element des Pinks, was nie in Filmen dargestellt wird, hier unbedingt mal anmelden.
Zu den Fails kommen wir gleich.
Das ist kein Fail, das ist ein strukturelles, kulturelles Problem.
Leute, ich bin wirklich entsetzt.
Okay, dann schließe ich mich wohl an 23. Die darstellung finde ich natürlich die zeitgenössische Darstellung finde ich heute schon wieder doppelt interessant, weil sie nicht nur tagging gut darstellt, sondern weil sie auch die Computertechnik dieser Zeit cool darstellt, die ja viele einfach jetzt, wenn die heute sich den Film angucken, nicht mehr kennen können.
Aber du hast ja oder ihr habt ja beraten bei Who Am I?
Ich noch nicht, das war vor meiner Zeit.
Ja, so genau, das müsste ja, wenn jeder sozusagen mit dabei oder du, muss das ja besonders gut gelungen sein, oder? Oder andersrum gefragt. Wie groß war denn die Diskrepanz zwischen deiner Beratung und das, was du nachher im Film gesehen hast?
Nee, ich würde das nicht so sehen, wie bei 23 war, wo das ja eine richtig enge Zusammenarbeit war und da ja auch einfach, da waren Menschen, die dabei waren, die darüber berichtet haben. Das ist ja anders, als wenn du ein Screenplay bekommst oder eine Vorform war das sogar. Und dann dazu dich mit denen mal hin unterhältst. Die klopfen so ein bisschen ab, was ist denn daran realistisch oder war das einfach unsinnig so? Davon gab es mehrere Iterationen, aber keine Filmberatung in dem Sinne, wie das bei 23 stattgefunden hat, sondern das mehr so ein, wie kann man das machen?
Aber trotzdem, also du sagst, das war sehr im Vorfeld, aber trotzdem hast du dann im Film Fails gesehen, wo du dann gedacht hast so, boah, ich hab doch gesagt, das sollt ihr nicht so machen oder haben die alles umgesetzt?
Also ich persönlich fand ich, anders als Kaspar, diese künstlerische Umsetzung mit den Tubes nicht so gelungen. Also ich fand schon den Aspekt, wie man Anonymität jemanden begreiflich macht, der jetzt irgendwie selber noch nie Dark Knight benutzt hat oder so, schon. Aber die Wiederholung war mir zu häufig. Es soll natürlich künstlerisch auch ein Muster sein, wenn man wieder erkennt, das ist mir irgendwie auch klar, das kann ein Cognitive verstehen, aber mir ging es auf den Kranz.
Kasper, du hast, ich würde zu den Fails kommen wollen. Kasper, du hast doch eine Szene mitgebracht aus dem Film, oder?
Ja, genau, ich habe aus HohemEi, das war lustig, weil wir haben im Vorfeld kurz gesprochen und da hatte ich gesagt, ich habe doch hier einen HohemEi. Ich lese mal kurz einen Dialog aus HohemEi vor. Benjamin war der eine und wie ist der andere, der andere Hauptcharakter? Max fragt Benjamin, was hast du nur verbrochen? Benjamin hat einen Uni-Server gehackt. Max, und wie bist du durch deren Access Control gekommen? Benjamin mit einem Zero-Day-Exploit. Jetzt muss ich kurz pausieren. Dieser Dialog macht Sinn.
Kurz Zero-Day-Exploit?
Genau, ich erkläre kurz. Also erst mal der eine sagt, ich habe einen Uni-Server gehackt, kann man sich vorstellen. Das andere, wie bist du durch deren Access Control gekommen? Also wie bist du irgendwie durch deren Firewall, was auch immer, Benutzer, okay, versteht man auch. Mit einem Zero-Day-Exploit heißt, er hat einen Crack verwendet, der noch nicht bekannt ist.
Eine Sicherheitslücke?
Eine Sicherheitslücke, die noch nicht bekannt ist öffentlich. Das nennt sich Zero-Day-Exploit. Bis dahin ist es gut. Und jetzt antwortet Max darauf, du kannst Maschinensprache lesen, einfach so. Und dieser Satz macht auf so vielen Ebenen keinen Sinn. Das ist mir wirklich, weil ich dachte so, endlich mal ein realistischer, ne doch nicht. Und ja, genau.
Ich habe seitdem davon erzählt, dass du versuchst zu sagen, so eine Analogie zu finden. Ich scheite so ein bisschen, aber es ist so ähnlich wie jemand sagt, boah, du hast diesen Kuchen gebacken und dann sagt der andere, ja, ich weiß, wie man Trecker auseinanderbaut. Es hat ganz am Rande was damit zu tun.
Aber ich habe immerhin ein Erklärungsmodell dafür. Ihr könnt mir vorstellen, wenn ich weiß, was ein Zero-Day-Exploit ist, aber die Null sieht in geschriebener Form, der denkt an Nullen und Einsen und denkt an Maschinenkotten.
Oh mein Gott, ja, wegen Zero und Nullen und Einsen.
Ich möchte aber hier betonen, dass ich in diesem Stadion nichts mehr mit dem Screenplay zu tun hatte und keine Verantwortung übernehme. Kannst du dich an die Szene erinnern?
Das ist halt eine Diskrepanz zwischen der Realität und dem Realismus im Film. Das kommt auch in der Serie You Are Wanted vor. Also ganz plausibel. Das Auto, der Hauptfigur, wird gehackt und er verliert Kontrolle des Wagens komplett. Ich finde das plausibel, wenn man an Teslas denkt, die in San Francisco ohne einen Fahrer sind. Aber dann gibt es fragwürdigere Texte, zum Beispiel, wenn ein Aufzug in einem Krankenhaus nicht mehr funktioniert, weil man das gehackt hat, ist das vielleicht übertrieben.
Also ich fand You Are Wanted unerträglich, was die Hack-Szenen angeht. Also eine nach der anderen hat mir körperliche Schmerzen geweilt.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass wir heute so viel drüber reden. Das müssen wir noch mal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr erzählen. You Are Wanted ist eine Amazon Prime Serie, glaube ich, gewesen. Eine deutsche Auftragsposition, wo Matthias Hacker für den Bösewicht, glaube ich, spielt. Der ist der Betroffene. Es geht um einen Typen, der wird halt sozusagen von einem bösen Hacker unter Druck gesetzt, mehr oder weniger. Und da wollte ich übrigens fragen, William, ist das für dich eine deutsche Produktion? Also im Sinne, siehst du die im selben Kanon wie all die anderen Sachen, die du beschrieben hast? Oder versuchen hier deutsche, US-amerikanisches Hacker-Fernsehen nachzumachen?
Ja, das ist auch die Frage mit Billion Dollar Code. Aber ich sehe die beide ähnlich, wie sie umgehen. Und ich finde das immer noch als Realismus. Also inwiefern das überdramatisiert wird, das ist eine andere Frage. Aber es versucht halt die Realität darzustellen und sogar in der deutschen Kultur. Also ja, das gehört meinetwegen zu der Genre.
Ich muss jetzt unbedingt Caspar fragen, ob er eine Szene konkret in Erinnerung hat, die ihm körperliche Schmerzen bereitet hat. Weißt du jetzt eine?
Ja, ich hab mir jetzt nochmal die erste Folge einfach nochmal angeguckt, um es aufzufrischen. Das fängt schon damit an. Ich spoil jetzt ein bisschen, aber nicht zu sehr. Der Hacker guckt über sowas wie so ein Alexa-Screen-Bildschirm in die Wohnung rein und da steht das Kind. Und der Hacker guckt dadurch, dass das Kind sich dann, also da geht der Bildschirm an, die Webcam und dann sieht das Kind sich aber selber. Und ich frag mich, was soll das technisch? Also das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, das würde ein Hacker nie machen. Das macht technisch keinen Sinn. Ja, vielleicht fällfilmisch.
Das finde ich total interessant, weil der, also das ist in dir so ein Sagen, so wie den großen Puls, weil ich aus einer rein erzählerischen Perspektive den Hacker sozusagen, das weiß man zumindest am Anfang, nicht ob der ein Ziel hat, sondern der will ja nur Stress machen. Und das finde ich sozusagen, einem Kind ein Gerät anzumachen, das hat es also nicht selber bedient, sich dann sich selber zu zeigen, finde ich eine ganz valide Form, um so eine Art Horror in diesen, das kann man so mit Gastleitung auch verbinden. Was hast du da gemacht? Ich habe gar nichts gemacht, aber wieso ist dann die Kamera an?
So habe ich das noch nicht gesehen, das ist interessant. Und ansonsten gibt es da immer so diese Szenen, wo Schweighöfer an seinem Rechner sitzt und dann immer so ganz viele Fenster so dramatisch auf und zu gehen. Und ich denke so, ja, echt jetzt. Dabei, es gibt auch gute Szenen da drin, nämlich wo der dann seinen Computer neu aufsetzt, einfach wirklich Windows neu installiert und davon genervt ist. Und dann denke ich so, ja, das ist auch, also da finde ich auch den Charakter nachvollziehbar. Der denkt, ich bin gehackt worden. Ich installiere Windows neu, schön. Hat er gelesen, der Computerbild. So, aber die diese, wenn er wirklich gehackt wird gerade immer, das ist jedes Mal so, ich denke so, nee, echt, also da sind wir filmisch einfach schon weiter gewesen. Das fand ich sehr, sehr retro, was sie da gezeigt haben.
Mich würde wirklich interessieren, wie das hinter den Kulissen aussieht, inwieweit da Leute berichtig beraten und dann irgendjemand anders sagt so, nee, wir machen das trotzdem so. Falls ihr Einblick habt, schreibt in die Kommentare oder uns eine Mail.
Oder beauftragt uns, wir beraten auch nicht.
Also ja, es ist dasselbe Genre wie die anderen, aber ja, es ist noch mehr Richtung Hollywood auf jeden Fall. Und deswegen kann es mit den Ängsten eines heutzutagigen Publikums spielen.
Ich würde jetzt langsam auf ihr Ziel gerade einbiegen wollen.
Oh nein.
Entschuldigung, dass wir heute keine drei Stunden oder vier Stunden Sessionen und fragen wollen. Die Art und Weise, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben, also gerne auch mit Fokus auf deutsche Produktion. Wie seht ihr die Wechselwirkung? Also William, bei dir aus der Ferne kannst du das ja sozusagen mehr oder weniger nur beurteilen. Die Wechselwirkung zwischen wie verändern Filme das Hackerbild in der Öffentlichkeit und wie verändert vielleicht die Darstellung auch die Hackerwelt selber? Das finde ich, also vielleicht kann auch von euch einer was dazu sagen. Also wie, also gibt es mittlerweile Hacker-Mannirismen, die vielleicht davon kommen, dass Hacker in den Medien oder in den fiktiven Medien sozusagen auf so eine Artweise dargestellt. Also welche Wechselwirkung gibt es zwischen der Darstellung von Hackern in Filmen und TV und den Hosenwelt-HackerInnen?
Ja, müsste man euch fragen, ob die Darstellung von Hackern euch beeinflusst. Irgendwie und ja, also das Streaming macht doch eine Wirkung. Also wenn man Netflix etwas aus Deutschland schauen darf, dann hat man ja eine andere Position, die man überlegen könnte.
Mir fällt eine Frage, Entschuldigung, zu mir seid, die ich vergessen habe zu stellen und William, das wollte ich nämlich dich vor allen Dingen wegen der Außenperspektive fragen. Sind hackende Personen im deutschen Film und Fernsehen nur Männer?
Nein, aber die Hauptfiguren doch. Also man sieht in You Are Wanted, es gibt Frauen im Zimmer. Und das ist der Fall bei all diesen Beispielen, dass es Frauen im Zimmer gibt. Und ja, doch in 23 hat Kauf eine Beziehung mit einer, die immer da ist und teilnimmt. Aber ja, leider gibt es keine Hauptfigurinnen bisher in solchen Filmen. Also in Dokumentarfilmen doch, aber in, sagen wir, Feature Films gibt es keine Frau in der Hauptrolle als Hacker bisher.
Es gibt ja diesen Bechteltest, der ist ja mittlerweile auch im Stritten, aber sozusagen so als Daumenregel, finde ich, kann man immer noch kurz gucken, der sagt, der die Frage stellt, gibt es in Filmen sozusagen Frauen, die sich miteinander unterhalten über was anderes als Männer? Und ich fürchte sozusagen für Hackerinnen im deutschen Film und Fernsehen ist die Antwort da ganz eindeutig nein.
Wenn es keine gibt, wie sollen sie sich unterhalten?
Sie sind halt nur im Zimmer, sie sind halt bei Werk, oder?
Würde ich auch, also im deutschen Film bleiben.
Da fällt euch denn einer in einem Ami?
Ihr habt ja schon genannt die Angelina Jolie und auch sind es die Glasenverfilmungen.
Ihr habt keine Ahnung, wie oft ich darauf angesprochen wurde damals. Ich habe ja zwei Filme davon. Unglaublich, weil das so selten war. Ich war überschwemmt von Presseanfragen, als diese Filme rauskamen. Da war ein zeitlicher Versatz. Es gibt eine schwedische und skandinavische Produktion und eine Ami-Produktion, oder?
Genau, die schwedische ist besser. Ich finde die auch, natürlich.
Man sollte auch die Serie erwähnen, Biohackers. Das ist eine deutsche Serie mit einer Frau in der Hauptrolle. Sie experimentiert, aber nicht nur mit Computern, nicht mit Programmier-Sprache.
Der Bechteltest wird ja auch nicht bestanden, wenn es nur eine Frau als Hauptrolle gibt. Das ist eben das Wichtigste.
Sie könnte sich mit einer Nebenrolle über was anderen unterhalten.
Genau, aber wenn es keine Namen gibt und sie müssen sich unterhalten und nicht über Männer und da wird es tatsächlich dann schwierig.
Wie würdet ihr Trinity, also weil Matrix ja sozusagen auch so, also würdet ihr Trinity, also den Charakter von Carrie and Moss in Matrix sozusagen als weibliche Hackerin oder als Beiwerk?
Och die ist schon Hacker, aber reden tut sie nicht viel.
Na beides, weil auch wieder sie, und das soll jetzt nicht abfällig klingen, sondern wirklich als filmische Beschreibung. Sie ist halt auch sexuelles Objekt für den Hauptcharakter nachher. Also er erobert sie ja, also doch wieder so ein ganz klassischer Plot. Das heißt, sie ist nicht eine unabhängige, nicht Sexpartnerin.
Ja, aber Keanu Reeves ist bitteschön auch echt ein Sexobjekt. Aber was für jetzt? Also ich würd's da nun mal nicht unerwähnten lassen. Das ist nicht so mein Fall, aber...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir möchten Indie Kings, der Sprecherin des Chaos Computer Club, an dieser Stelle nicht weiter eingehen, sondern zurück zur Frage kommen, welche Wechselwirkungen ihr zwischen der Darstellung von Hackern, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben, im deutschen Film und Fernsehen, seht mit dem Rest der Welt.
Für mich ist es relativ deutlich, ich hab manchmal in den letzten Jahren Vorträge darüber gehalten, wie die fünf schlimmsten Mythen zu debanken über Hacker. Weil ich glaube, dass es eine starke Rückwirkung gibt, aber weniger von diesen deutschen Filmen. Ich glaube, dass die deutschen Filme unter Deutschen immer noch sehr viel weniger gesehen werden, als die Hollywood Schinken. Und vor allen Dingen die Hollywood Vorabendserien, also diese CSI-Hacking, ist glaube ich das Allerschlimmste. Die sind I need three minutes and I'm in und egal wo.
Zu zweit an einer Tastatur.
Und mehrere Dinge, wenn man darüber ernsthaft spricht und Leute sich für Hacker interessieren und zum Beispiel einen einladen, sodass man darüber spricht, dann kann man diese Klischees aus den Filmen immer wieder abrufen, weil Leute in ihrer Lebenswelt mit keinem Hacker in Kontakt kommen und in ihrer einzige Darstellung ist. Und deswegen ist, also für mich ist die extrem wirkungsmächtig nach wie vor. Darf ich jetzt endlich mal sagen, was da fehlt, was mich so ärgert seit Jahren, darf ich jetzt sagen? Niemand liest da mal ein Manual. Niemand. Also Hackerleben besteht in hohem Maße davon, sich mal mit den Details eines technischen Systems ausnahm zu setzen. Dazu muss man diese blöden Manuals lesen. Und nie taucht das auch nur auf. Das wird nicht mal erwähnt in den Filmen. Das regt mich auf. Jawohl. Das wollte ich jetzt hier endlich mal gesagt haben. Also auch in meinem Hackerleben, das ist ja nicht nur Software, das ist auch Hardware. Du musst dich mit diesem System, mit den Spezifikationen beschäftigen. Macht überhaupt keinen Spaß, das zu lesen. Und man muss auch lang, also weißt du, dieser ganze Vorlaufprozess findet auch nie statt. Die sind immer schon alle auf einem gewissen Level. Man muss sich nie einarbeiten in Systeme. Das regt mich schon seit Jahren um. So, fertig. Fertig und beregt.
Ich würde es ähnlich beantworten, wie Constanze das indirekt oder direkt getan hat. Ja, es gibt eine Wechselwirkung auf jeden Fall zwischen filmischer Welt und realer Welt. Aber die besteht auch in Deutschland nur sehr wenig auf der Basis von deutschen Produktion. Filme wie 23 und so sind keine Blockbuster, die irgendwie die Wohnungen vollgestopft haben mit Menschen, die geguckt haben, sondern die Klischees und die Sachen kommen viel mehr aus großen internationalen Produktionen, die aber auch eben aus Schweden kommen können, ja, plötzlich. Aber die deutschen Filme sind eher für mich immer etwas Retrospektives, das sich mit der eigenen Geschichte befasst, wie zum Beispiel auch diese RF-Feature-Filme. Also da würde ich eher die deutsche Filmkultur sehen.
Wobei wir einen dabei hatten, den man hier als Blockbuster bezeichnen kann. Also Who Am I war auch kommerziellen Erfolg.
Aber war das in Deutschland auch?
Aber war ja kommerziellen Erfolg oder war es sozusagen so ein richtiger Top 10?
Also hat William in seinem Buch geschrieben, stimmt das nicht?
Tja, keiner war ganz erfolgreich, besonders am Anfang. Aber dass man immer noch 23 sieht oder sehen möchte. Oder es ist wieder aufgetaucht.
Das kann man natürlich auf zwei Arten lesen. Man kann sagen, das ist ein so guter Film, dass man jetzt immer noch sehen will. Man könnte auch sagen, seitdem ist halt einfach nichts gekommen, was dem das Wasser reichen kann. Das heißt, es ist auch so ein bisschen Dürre hier. Zum Schluss habe ich noch zwei Fragen. Die erste ist, ob ihr kurz einen Tipp abgeben könnt. Es ist ja in der Medienwelt oder generell in der Welt, findet ja leider oft Amerikalisierung statt. Und wir haben jetzt irgendwie You Are Wanted schon gesagt. Also das ist was, das orientiert sich halt sehr stark an Hollywood. Auch Who Am I kann man dem? Glaubst du, William, vielleicht wird sich, du hast ja, du hast ja deutsches Film, also Hacker an deutschen Filmen und Fernsehen als eigenständiges Gebiet untersucht. Glaubst du, dass es das in Zukunft auch noch geben wird? Also dass Hacker in deutschen Filmen und Fernsehen sich so sehr unterscheiden werden von US-amerikanischen Produktionen, dass sich das als Untersuchungsgebiet lohnt oder wird sich das einfach angleichen, weil es sich besser verkauft?
Das ist eine große Frage und ich meine, dass die Antworten von Kaspar und Constanze ganz schön das dargestellt haben. Und ja, Berlin ist auch schon amerikanisiert. Noch stärker in den letzten zehn Jahren kann man sagen. Also ja, es wird noch deutsche Vorstellungen von Hackern geben, aber das wird auch zum anderen Teil immer internationaler. Vielleicht nicht amerikanisiert, sondern internationalisiert.
Ich glaube auch, dass diese jetzt schon mehrfach, es hat ja gefallen, Netflix Produktion oder Amazon Prime oder so. Ich denke, die machen was. Meine Beobachtung ist, dass die meisten dieser deutschen Produktionen sind Co-Produktionen. Das heißt, da gibt es auch eine organisatorische Zusammenarbeit und auch eine, die sich auf ein internationales Publikum richtet, weil sie sie von vornherein so vermarkten. Wenn ihr euch anguckt, was zum Beispiel auch jetzt die aktuellen großen ARD Produktionen sind, Co-Produktionen, die mit technischen Themen zu tun haben. Die sind in Englisch gedreht mit deutschen Schauspielern. Das heißt, da gibt es ein Zugehen auf diese Märkte. Haben wir eigentlich schon über Bollywood geredet? Oder Nollywood? Na gut, also mein Eindruck ist, das ist auch von den...
Jetzt musst du kurz sagen, was das ist.
Bollywood, hallo, der größte Filmmarkt in Indien. Und Nollywood ist sozusagen das afrikanische Pendant. Also egal, also ich kann mich selber wieder unterbrochen.
Müssen wir jetzt noch mal ein eigenes Chaos Radio über Bollywood und Nollywood Hackerfilme machen?
Aus meiner Sicht müssen wir dringend diesen Podcast fortführen, weil wir auch nur weniger Aspekte ansprechen konnten. Wir müssen das unbedingt fortführen. Und wir wissen, wie wir das fortführen. Ich hab eine Idee, darf ich das live hier auch näher sagen?
Raushacken, Entschuldigung.
Naja, ich meine, am spannendsten ist es doch letztlich so wie in Williams Buch, wenn man es am einzelnen Film und an einer einzelnen Figur festmacht. Also wenn man sich ein konkretes Beispiel sucht und daran die Klischees oder nicht Klischees, die da schon gesagt wird, kulturell festmacht.
Also ihr könnt schon mal gucken, ob Hackercast.de noch frei ist. Vielleicht ist hier gerade ein neuer Podcast geboren worden. Caspar, wolltest du auch noch zur möglichen Amerikanisierung, Internationalisierung von Hacker, deutschen Hacker filmen?
Ich fand es schön, was William gesagt hat, dass Berlin ja auch amerikanisiert wurde als gebürtige Berliner. Wo ich sagen Aua, ja. Also nun ist es natürlich komisch mit jemanden, der gerade in Amerika ist, das als etwas Schlechtes darzustellen. Das dachte ich auch, das ist auch ein bisschen blöd. Aber ich glaube, wir wissen alle, was gemeint ist. Als ich Billion Dollar Code geguckt habe, war ich sehr berührt emotional, weil ich habe meine Jugend in den 90er Jahren gesehen. Also ich war echt kurz, ich hatte so eine Träne im Knopfloch und habe so gesehen, so Orte wie die Seabase und Hacker Club so vor Augen wieder in der Oranienburger Straße und dachte so, man, war das eine schöne Zeit hier. Die war auch wirklich toll so. Und es war interessant, das aber in so einer Produktion zu sehen. Also da bringt das auch was Gutes hervor, weil auch das Geld da ist, um diese Zeit wieder aufleben zu lassen. Das kostet ja auch Produktionsgelder, das alte Berlin darzustellen. Aber so wie sich Berlin verändert, werden sich auch die Filmproduktionen verändern. Das denke ich auch, ja.
Ja, wenn ich sagen darf, Berlin ist noch meine Lieblingsstadt. Also je mehr die Rolle eines deutschen Hackers sich ändert, ich meine internationale, desto mehr wird das bei den Filmen reflektiert. Also die Filme sind eine Reflektion der Realität, auch wenn sie übertrieben sind.
Okay, so dann allerletzte Abschlussrunde mit der Arschblustrage, mit der Bitte um kurze Antwort. Wenn man sich jetzt diesen Podcast angehört hat und vorher noch nicht, also es nicht irgendwie gerade innerlich seine eigene Bibliothek durchgeht und denkt, aha, ja ja, sondern wenn man jetzt neu an das Thema einsteigen will, als Empfehlung und vielleicht als Positivempfehlung, also nicht sozusagen schlimmster Hacker-Fehlfilm, sondern der eine Hacker-Film, wo ihr sagt, wenn man einsteigen will, Caspar zeigt, er möchte gerne drei Titel sagen, na gut, aber ihr anderen müsst nicht drei sagen, also eure Lieblings, euer Lieblingshacker-Film oder wenn es sein muss, eure drei Lieblingshacker-Filme oder Serien. Dann Caspar, fang noch mal an.
Okay, also ich muss einfach 23 sagen, das ist historisch auch interessant. So, da lernt man was über Geschichte. Ich finde Hackers aus Amerika einfach witzig, das ist popkulturell wichtig. Und einen Film möchte ich noch pitchen, den wir gar nicht genannt haben. 1987, Deutschland, der Film Peng, du bist tot, wo Rolf Zacher einen Hacker spielt und der aber enorm interessant ist in der Darstellung von Hack und den gibt es auf einer Videoplattform irgendwie umsonst zu gucken, glaube ich, wenn man da irgendwie nach Peng, du bist tot googelt.
Also ich könnte mich bei den allen drei anschließen. Es liegt aber daran, dass wir über Peng, du bist tot, man kein Schwein kennt schon mal den Sprachern vor langer Zeit. Von den Büchern, die William am Buch hat, würde ich glaube ich am ehesten den Billion Dollar Code angucken, weil das eben auch ja die Stadt ist da schön porträtiert, die Charaktere haben eine gewisse Tiefe, also einfach schöne Art finde ich. Ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, ob ich noch einen Film kenne. Also ich finde nicht uninteressant, wenn man sich ein bisschen für diese kulturelle Hacker-Bild interessiert, die Matrix Trilogie. Ist das eine Trilogie? Ich glaube ich kenne nur drei. Also sich nochmal anzusehen, denn da ist ja auch dieses Konzept in was reinzuhacken, die Realität mit damit zu ändern, finde ich auch interessant. Das ist für, also das war mal ein Blockbuster, aber ich glaube, dass jüngere Leute den heute gar nicht mehr so kennen, weil der so ein bisschen ist jetzt einfach so ein bisschen abgehangen. Und ich finde es lohnt sich, wenn man den ganzen Ballast von diesem religiösen Überbau da wegdenkt, sich nochmal anzusehen, wie der Hacker da dargestellt ist, wie unterschiedlich die Hacker sind.
Ich tue mich schwerer, weil ich bei Beatrix bin, ich bin immer so, also guck den ersten Teil, guck Zusammenfassung für Teil zwei und drei, guck den vierten Teil. Ich glaube, das ist alles, was man akkert. Ich finde von den Filmen aus dem Buch von Wilhelm, ich war total überrascht. Ich hatte nämlich damals Who Am I ausgelassen, weil ich dachte, das ist bestimmt ganz schlimm. Ich hab den jetzt in der Vorbereitung der Sendung geguckt und es ist einfach also auch sehr immer sein Section Kino. Also das ist sozusagen eine gute Abendunterhaltung, wenn er mal die Füße hochlegen wollte und das ein bisschen knallpeng puff macht. Also gut gelungen. William, du musst anscheinend, wenn du es noch nicht getan hast, peng, du bist totgucken. Habe ich jetzt so als Hausaufgabe von den anderen beiden an dich mit vernommen. Was sind denn deine Hackfilmempfehlungen?
Tja, wenn man nur aktuelle Filme oder aktuelles Fernsehen mag und nur etwas aus der jetzigen Zeit sehen möchte, dann auf jeden Fall Billion Dollar Code. Ich finde den Vergleich zwischen Silicon Valley und Berlin super interessant, muss man schauen. Ansonsten, wenn man auch alte Filme mag, dann auf jeden Fall 23. Die Gedanken sind frei. Die drei singen David und Carl auf einem Zug. Also wenn man sich nur ein bisschen für die deutsche Geschichte interessiert, dann gibt es so viel einen Film ganz sehenswert. Ja, also die beiden.
Was ist das eigentlich mit Berlin-Babylon? Nein, das sind ja nicht wirklich Hackerfiguren.
Meine Deutsch-Studentinnen in den USA schauen die Serie schon. Ich habe auch vor, vielleicht über Dark zu schreiben.
Vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr heute alle hier wart. Vielen Dank, William, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Dein Buch heißt Hackers as Heroes in German Film and Television. Ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz billig, weil es ein wissenschaftliches Buch vor allem ist, aber es ist lesenswert, das kann ich tatsächlich sagen. Vielen lieben Dank, dass du da warst. Vielen lieben Dank Caspar und Constanze, dass ihr da wart. Und liebe HörerInnen, viel Spaß beim Gucken. Ich verabschiede mich auch, mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüttelt immer schön eure Backups.